Привіт! Ми «Cultnaked».
Ми — український бренд фешн-одягу.
Ми засновані 2018 року, і наша місія —
зробити сексі-одяг комфортним.
Щомісяця нас обирають уже тисячі клієнтів.
60% нашої реалізації відбувається в Штатах,
Британія, Австралія, Європа, Китай так само.
У нас одягаються такі знаменитості,
як Кендал Дженнер,
Кайлі Дженнер, Аріана Ґранде, Ельза Госк.
Нас публікували американський «Forbes»,
«Vogue», «Who would wear»,
«Harper's Bazaar», «Elle», і всі ці публікації —
це наша велика гордість.
Тому що ми насправді — дуже інді-бренд з України.
Ми зовсім не великі, але речі, які ми робимо, —
притаманні великим брендам.
Ідея створення бренду одягу
до мене прийшла дуже давно,
тому що я не хотіла завжди бути
просто фотографом, хотіла мати свій бізнес.
І в мене завжди була ця проблема з носінням одягу,
я завжди хотіла виглядати як знаменитість,
коли я кудись виходила — на вечірку
або ще кудись, просто надвір з друзями.
І я почала з того, що купувала якийсь простий одяг
і різала його, обрізала, перешивала.
Просто за годину до вечірки — всі сидять уже вдома,
готуються, п'ють якесь просекко,
а я сиджу і штопаю якусь незрозумілу штуку,
а всі такі: «Що це буде таке?».
Потім я це одягаю, і всі: «О, це круто».
Я завжди старалася виглядати досить унікально.
А потім люди в інстаграмі почали мене питати:
«А що, що ти носиш? Що це за плаття?
Де його можна купити?».
І я така: «Окей, це гарна бізнес-ідея».
Для старту й оптимізації
першого року роботи,
нам потрібно було тридцять тисяч доларів
для того, щоб усе це реалізувати,
поки ми не вийшли в плюс.
Це насправді сталось дуже швидко
і це в мірках фешн-індустрії не дуже великі гроші.
Але це все можна зробити і набагато дешевше,
знаючи зараз, яких помилок
ми допустилися на початку.
Нам знадобилося вісім місяців,
щоб повністю відбити ці кошти.
Я ці гроші позичила, і ми їх віддали.
І це в принципі дуже реальна сума,
якщо ти дуже багато працюєш
і йдеш до своєї цілі, і в тебе є основна ідея.
Це насправді дуже легко
та швидко можна відбити,
якшо правильно це все запустити.
Тому я вірю, що це все дуже
реально для будь-кого, справді.
Я просто дуже рішуча людина насправді.
Я така: «Я буду робити бренд.
Я просто буду робити те, що я ношу».
Ось, і я взяла свою подругу й
ми поїхали в Італію шукати тканини.
І це був просто неймовірний досвід,
тому що ми взагалі нічого не знали.
Ми не знали, як це робиться,
де брати що, куди треба їхати,
ми приїхали в Італію, в Мілан,
поїхали в якийсь стоковий магазин,
а там були просто височенні ціни —
просто нереально,
і я така: «О, блін, у нас бізнес не вийде».
Тому що я не хотіла робити дуже дорогий бренд,
для мене було важливо,
щоб це було доступно таким самим, як я.
Ця подорож була просто дуже...
вона змінила наше життя по суті,
тому що ми дуже багато дізнались нового.
І потім, коли ми вже повернулись
в Україну і почали будувати свій цех,
закуповувати перші швейні машинки,
закуповувати, вже робити
цей стіл, знаходити персонал.
Перша конструкторка і перша швея —
це подруга моєї мами.
Десь так воно було.
Нас було троє в команді,
і на цьому піку, коли нас було троє
в команді, ми зробили перший скорт.
Це наш перший скорт.
Взагалі, «Cultnaked» я створила для того,
щоб вирішити проблему
не комфорту клубного одягу.
Це було насамперед...
Я дуже часто любила тусити та і взагалі.
І я дуже хотіла виглядати більш модною,
але я дуже люблю танцювати, постійно жарко
і ти не можеш одягати дуже багато одягу.
А ось тому я вирішила створити,
взяла натхнення з тенісу,
створити скорт, але крутий скорт.
Скорт — це коли спідниця має шорти,
наш найголовніший продукт.
Це найперше, що ми взагалі зробили для бренду.
Насправді я не думала, що це стане такою
нашою релігією.
Що у нас будуть скорти, скорти, скорти.
Я думала, що ми випустим один,
два таких і на цьому то закінчиться.
Аудиторія дуже сильно полюбила цей продукт.
Він суперзручний.
Це основне, це продукт,
який у нас продався, напевно, найбільше.
І він у нас із першого дня і буде до останнього.
Ми зробили перший скорт, я його спробувала,
одягнула вперше на Новий Рік 2018 року,
і 10 хвилин після того, як пробили
куранти у мене розійшовся замок.
Більше замки у нас не розходились після цього.
Через кілька місяців
ми підготували новий дроп,
і був «Paris Fashion Week»,
на який я полетіла з нашими речами.
Це було смішно, бо в нас ще не було
бірок, і вони мали б бути готові,
їх не зробили вчасно. Ми просто
на таких стрічках надрукували «Cultnaked».
Воно виглядало дуже жахливо,
а нам було важливо,
щоб люди, яких ми зустріли,
знали хоча б назву.
І я познайомилась з багатьма дуже цікавими мені,
підхожими для бренду інфлуенсерами
і просто подарувала їм речі.
Я ходила з такою сумкою,
і у мене там був завжди «Cultnaked»
будь-якого розміру для будь-якої моделі.
І мені пощастило подарувати скорт такій відомій
американській світській левиці Кароліні Вріланд.
Вона відома просто з народження,
бо її прапрабабця — це головна редакторка
«Vogue America» і «Harper’s Bazaar».
І вона, вся її ідеологія
дуже підходила до ідеології «Cultnaked»,
тому що вона завжди казала:
«Будьте святкові, одягайтесь».
Оце все мені дуже подобалось.
Через тиждень, я навіть не очікувала —
Кароліна знімає сторіс,
там, де вона в скорті, показує, що вона в скорті,
і наш інстаграм просто підривається.
Ось і так ми почали такий напрям із знаменитостями,
власне в маркетингу.
І потім я поїхала на «New York Fashion Week»,
і там сталась така смішна історія.
Там два стилісти випадково в той же день,
коли був «Victoria’s Secret Fashion Show Callback» —
це коли всіх моделей роблять на кастинг знов.
Дві моделі підряд були в нашому рожевому скорті.
А я летіла тоді в Нью-Йорк,
і я приземляюсь — а мій телефон
просто рве від того, що таке,
як це сталось, чи це підлаштували спеціально.
І стилісти були дуже злі з цього всього.
Але ми в інстаграмі отримали
дуже багато впізнаваності,
тому що дуже багато людей постили.
І це було дуже смішно,
тому що вони були зняті на відео,
а всі спільноти мали десь
20 мільйонів переглядів на відео.
Тоді це був наш перший час слави.
Ми цією подією були поставлені на карту.
Нам насправді дуже сильно пощастило.
Потім у нас був такий
трошки темний період у «Cultnaked»,
тому що у нас полетіла платіжна система на сайті,
а в Україні тоді ще не було
таких платіжних систем,
які могли б продавати так,
як нам потрібно було.
Це зараз усе трошки вже по-іншому відбувається,
а тоді платежі з-за кордону
дуже важко приймати було.
Хлопець, який робив сайт,
поставив сайт на тестовий режим.
І ми місяць продавались й не знали,
що продажі просто не проходили,
бо тому що це був тест,
і ми місяць відправляли всі посилки.
І попали просто в супербагато грошей.
А в нас така ситуація,
на початку бізнесу це дуже важко,
бо треба операційні кошти,
щоб рухатися далі.
І я чесно тоді думала, що ми закриємось,
але, слава Богу, ми якось вийшли з цієї ситуації.
І зараз «Cultnaked» є досі.
Всю увагу, яку ми отримали, як бренд,
ми зрозуміли, наскільки сильним
може бути бренд з України
і наскільки швидко може все розвиватись,
і це нам дало дуже великий поштовх
для наступних наших звершень.
Масштабних.
І ще буквально через певний час
одягає ще одна дуже відома співачка Нормані,
потім Аріана Ґранде.
У неї найбільше підписників
серед усіх жінок на інстаграм.
Прям випускає кліп у наших штанах.
І це дуже файно.
Це музичний кліп, Аріана Ґранде
виступає в наших штанах.
Це її перший перформанс за 500 з чимось днів,
тому це була дуже велика подія насправді.
Аріана Ґранде — це топ Spotify жіночого.
Взагалі, топ артист Spotify,
тому що в неї найбільше прослуховувань
і топ інстаграм-особистість з жінок.
Тобто більше фоловерів тільки в Роналдо.
У неї приблизно 200 мільйонів, 240 мільйонів?
244 мільйони.
Всього лиш 244 мільйони.
І вона запостила три фотографії підряд у наших штанах.
Плюс потім вона постила відео,
і ми дуже пишаємося цим прекрасним моментом.
Модель нашого бізнесу
дуже сильно відрізняється тим,
що ми, на відміну від брендів «швидкої моди»,
піклуємося про довкілля і
не робимо дуже великих запасів речей.
У нас немає сезонності, і коли,
наприклад, клієнт щось замовляє,
ми це робимо просто протягом
найближчих трьох днів,
і наші клієнти, хоча це займає
довший час і довше йде,
наприклад, доставка з України в США,
наші клієнти про це знають,
ми дуже добре робимо маркетинг
у соціальних мережах
і ми дуже добре спілкуємось з клієнтами,
і вони очікують того, що це буде трошки довше,
але це буде більш дружньо для довкілля.
Це найкрутіші штани на планеті.
Я зараз розповім чому.
Тому що вони роблять дуже класно,
у них дуже класна посадка по фігурі.
Вони трохи вужчі тут,
ніж в інших брендів зазвичай.
Тому що часто жінки стикаються із проблемою того,
що всі штани ось тут прямі.
Тому ми їх тут трошки звузили,
і вони дуже-дуже довгі,
тож роблять ноги дуже довгими,
але якщо комусь вони занадто довгі
їх можна просто відрізати.
Це наша основна фішка.
І їх дуже люблять Кендалл Дженнер
й Аріана Гранде,
і Нормані, і всі дуже класні дівчата.
Якщо ви хочете виходити на іноземні ринки,
в мене є декілька порад.
Перша: треба точно знати мову.
Друга: треба розбиратись у культурі цієї країни.
Це дуже важливо,
бо якщо ти не знаєш свого клієнта,
то ти ніколи йому не зможеш продати.
І, певно, третя: це бути проактивним, не боятись,
писати туди, куди тобі треба писати,
і хотіти продавати кудись,
не на території України,
а там у Париж або в Маямі, я не знаю.
І потрібно знаходити там людей,
а щоб знаходити там людей
потрібно з ними комунікувати.
І це дуже часто стає великою перепоною,
тому що багато людей соромляться,
але не треба соромитися.
В наших цілях взагалі —
надихати українську молодь
від Львова до Севастополя робити глобальні бренди,
тому що це можливо.
Це все можливо зробити
і можливо це все робити класно,
і можливо масштабуватись
і працювати з класними людьми
зі Штатів, з Британії і так далі,
і ми хочемо показати своїм прикладом —
я персонально...
Я вважаю, що це моя місія:
допомогти більшій кількості жінок робити бізнес.
Я персонально займаюсь,
часто консультую молоді бренди,
розповідаю їм, відкриваю всі карти,
даю всі контакти, розповідаю, як це зробити.
Для мене це не про конкуренцію,
це про розвиток узагалі
економіки держави насправді.
Тому вперед, дівчата, нумо робити щось разом.